oh god i love how real they keep it
please welcome sherry shepherd and kim
whitley aka
two funny mamas
hey drew how you doing oh my god i love
you so much this is so exciting i love
you too
you guys really tackle so many different
types of
tones and genres and subjects and i love
the way that you mix it all into this
one
pot and make it all work together you
know
we but we've known each other for so
long
and i was there when kim adopted
joshua and she was there when i had
jeffrey
so we would always commiserate together
and we just
we don't hold back anything like you
know drew during this pandemic
we are both depressed we have these kids
24 7 around us i know we're supposed to
be bonding
i think we're supposed to be binding kim
but i'm like i need you
to go home school with somebody else
right and we really i was excited about
this podcast two funny mamas because
we're two funny mamas
and we're on tour together doing our
stand up and we just feel like we have
something to offer the world
you know especially during this pandemic
that we can give advice
and have fun if we can you know uh
entertain you
and give you advice uh it gives us joy
well and like one minute you'll be
talking about like mental health
and the next minute you know you'll be
saying something which
i think in comedy how do you transition
you know out of mental health and your
transition
is amazing oh thank you
i i do appreciate that you know we never
think about it because it's so
natural for us that we share uh we cry
together we
laugh together we fight so i i think
it's
just being in in during these hard times
that we're vulnerable and just like you
drew and sherry can attest to this
that once you show your truth and we're
comedians
they expect that if if i'mma let sherry
say something she has new hair
i think uh in life you have to be
transparent
you know because we're comics we look at
the world and you know this because you
dated a comic
you look at the world in a kind of
skewed we don't look at it in like
circular or rectangle
everything is a weird shape the way we
look at life like for instance
uh i was trying to it turned out my son
was missing like
every assignment in his class he was not
turning in anything
and trying to tutor a teenager who
number one doesn't like you
number two doesn't like you and number
three
don't like you so trying to tutor him i
literally went outside and i sat on the
stairs and i cried
and i called kim and i'm crying and
she's like she was so funny she's like
wait a minute listen
cause she gets in the camera she goes
listen listen just put everything down
get a glass of wine are you drinking
wine right now okay get another glass of
wine
and then she went through to let me know
that i wasn't the only one
going through what i was going through
because i thought i was a failure as a
mother
i did i i didn't understand geometry and
algebra and
history and and she made me laugh
and that's the kind of thing it's like
you in during this time you got to have
connection
because otherwise you think you're the
only one that's going through what
you're going through and then you
realize other mothers are going through
the same
[Music]
thing